LET'S GO "OUT "GOOD EVENING, I'.
THE QAG.
CNN SENT AS,GROUP MAE ACTS
CORDING  TY , AND QUOTE,
PERCEIVED MEMBERS OF THE KABUL
SUCH AS MEMBERS OF THE SAW THI
JANUARY 6, WHERIOTERS, AS ANEXA
NANCY PELOSI.
>>!NANCY!COMING,
Y!WHERE ARE YOU, NANCYG FOR YOU.
>>INS AFTE
QAN VE FS
ED S
HE'SD N THE UNITEDTA
OUR DONIE O'SULLIVAN AT A TRUMP
RALLY.
>>
Y TOOK OVER AND THAT'S
>> THAT COULD HAPPEN TAKE NTROL?
>> WOULD YOU LIKE TO S IT
HAPPEN?>> IT
YOU KNOW WH
BECAUSE THE ELECTION SN
S.te
DOING THEIR OWN INVESTIGATION,
AND AT THE RIGHT TIME THEY'LL BE
TRRESIDE>> AND TRUMPLL HIS ER
SO FLYNN, A ARMY LEN
T UESE KINDCROWDS WITCO LIKTH H
PPMACAN'PPEN
HERE.
[  APPLAUS
>>ON
IT SHOULD HAPP>> NO SHOULD HAP.
NO REAN. IDDENLY
TRYING TO REWRITY SAYINGHE WCO,
WRITING ON LINE ABOUT GENECOMME
F ED ON 6.LICANS STILL REFUSE
LISTEN TO SENATOR ROJOF VIDEO OF
PEOPLE IE  AND THE
T RIING.
IT DOESN'T L AN ARMEINSU
BREACH T,
>>. I DON'THEY'RAYS IN TOTUNDA.E
WELL, WHAT DOES
INSURRECTION L, THERE'S -- THAT'
WHAT HAPPENED, IKNOW WHAT HEALL.
CONGRESSMAN CLYDE, YOU MAY
HEI EQUATHE LAST M
TO TOURISTS.
IF YOUT IT WAS,
ULD SAD THAT QUESTION WHEN
ASKETO
OF ALLIES ARE PRETTY
TTHAHA
JANUARY 6,N ATTEMPTED
OVERTURNING OF YOUR ELECTION,
ANTHEY MAY BE ALARMED BYE CONTI
TRUMP  REPUBLICAN E RISE O
KE HIM
AROU
WHAT DO YOU SAY TO T
>> IT IS AHO SURPRISE
THAT WHAT'N TERMS OF
TRUMP'S PHONY POPULISM HAS
HAPPENED.
MANY OF MYCAIN THE SENATE, WHO
BETTHAT
TAKE F INVESTIGATIOCA
WORRIED ABOUT BEING PRIMARIED. T
AT A PRESS CONFERENCE
HE WAS ASKED ABOUTVERY
ISSUE INRUSSELS ATRESSSEE REICT
WHO HAVE DOWNPLAYED THE EVENTS
OF THA
JOSH CAMPBELL IS OUT F LOS ANGES
ON THIS FBING. HAVE BEEN
TALKING TOAW ENFORCEMENTRTW SER
THESE CONCER
TAKING ACTION?
orter: UP UNTI
POINT,R CHRISTOPHER WRAY
IS SAYTH IS NOT ING THE MOVEMEN
INVESTIGATING INDIVIDUAL
AD THEY THEIR CONCERN THAT SOM .
THE FBI IS CTAINLYVE ADDITIONAL
WITO, FOR R VIEWERS WHO MAY NOT
UNDERSTAND THE NUTS AND BOLTS OF
THIS CONSPIRACY MOVENTELY BEEN
NOTIONROUP Q
GOING L KINDS OF
GOVERNMENT CORRUPTION.HE ADHEEAR
SAYING I
BUT THESE INDIGENOUSLDIERS WILL
CE.E S THIS
MYSTERIOUS LEADER TAKEN UP
HAS FAENEA THAT
KABUL OF PEDOPHILE
I CAN TE I COVERED LOT
OF DEMONSTRATIONS IN THE LAST
YEE
S. TO SHOW YOU PROOF
OF WHAT THD THEY TURN
IT AROUND ON YOU
USOF NOT ECAN SES YOS REALLY DA
HO FBI IS ABOUT IS THAT YOU HAVE
THESE PEOPLEHAYBE BECAUSE
OF THEIR FRUSTRATION WILL START
TO ACTITOLENCE.
WAS JUST MESSING
FEDETHHORTME AGO, AND SHE SAID
PERIL.
SH
ADRE , THATWORLD, BUT WHAT IS
CONCERNING LAW ENFORCEMENT IS
E PERSON
ED VIOLENCE TOOMHI
DEADLY.
A VE.
THANKOUMUCH,
ME  WELL
IT ISN'T, RIGHT?
IT'S PRETTY INCREDIBLE.
AND THE DEEPES O
PROBLEM.
OUONIE, NOW THE  OF LAW FOEME
ANTI-DEFAMATION LEAGUE WHICH
ANE O'SULLIVAN WHO HAS
ING THN .
SOD
GREG, LET ME START WITH YOU.
WHAT IS  CONCERN
ABOUT THESE DOMESTIC EXTREMISTS?
BECAUSE THAT'S WHAT TH ARE.
>> E FIRST, THANK U
ME.
JOCHE ENCAPSULATED VERY WELL,
NG THESEFRT OFY
EYES. THE MOST IN YEARS I
BEEN WORKINGH EXTREMISM.ERYTHIN
NOT HAPPEN AND TRUTH BECAME
E DESPERATE TO KEEIS IDEALOGY M.
WHAT THAT DOES TWO
DIFFERENT DANGEVS WARNING THESES
INCREASED RHETORIC ONLINE.
LONE ACTOR IN ORDER TO DO
SOMETHING, COMMIT A VIOLENT ACT?
RE, AND WHAT WE'REEING WQASPECI
USEDSE IDEALOGIES TO CREAT
UPSET.
QRT
REPUBLICANS IN THE ENTIRE UNITED
STAT AH BELIEFS LINKED
TO QANON. THE F REPORT,
ANT OF'S WILLINGNESS TO BELIEV
BUT ONE OF THOSEHINGS IS THE Y
PERSON THAT WOULD REFER TO IS OD
THE FO, O POURS QAN NARRATIVES.
FRAN THE WHOLE S
THG WAS RIGGED.
AREE
EN, DO
>> HANGINGN HIS EVERY
WORD, ERIN.
K WHEN WE TALK ABOUT
QANON, ACCORE QANON THIS BELF  ,
ETA.
REALLY,  TBOUT  I THINKTH IS ABE
IT'SBOLIS ABOUT
THE RING OF PEDOPHILES AND
SATANISTS AND IT'S MOR
THE ELECTION BEING STOLEN, AND
SINGLE DAY BCERTAIN SEGMENTS
OF THE M AND COURSE, BY .
AND, LK, IT CAN BE DIFFICULT YOE
SHOES OF A QANON ME PEOE GENUINY
BELIEVE THIS STUFF.
IF YOU THAT
THAT AMERICANCRY
U,N SEE
NYO JUSTIFY
VIOLENCE.
OR FBIHEYOU HAVE ICULT IS
ITROWE'VE NEVER SEENEFORE,ETER
IC MOVEMENT.
IT'S NOT LE AL QAEDA, FOR
AM W
RIGHTYOU COULD IDENTIFYM ANTHAT
WOULD HELP O T
LOOK FOR.
THAT DOES NOT EXIST REHAT'S COR
NOT WHAT WE WOULD CALL A
TRADITIONAL INVESTIGATION INTO U
FECRIME OR CARTEL WITH A E.
THAT'S DIFFICULT
THIS IS.
AKING THEIR OWN
INSTIO OR SOME KIND OF
DIRECTION.
THE FBI IS DOING WHA
BET ASIRECTOR WRAY HAS
MENTIONED, JUST BECAUSE YO
R
YOU'RE A MEMBER  QANON
NOT MA